[Music]
we're talking can anyone hear us
all right hey folks welcome to the dark
horse podcast
live stream where we face enemies who
create problems but this was not one of
those problems this was a problem that
we created for
ourselves sorry for the dead air at the
beginning um
things weren't feeling complicated
enough no they weren't complicated
enough
um but let's orient you all first of all
hopefully most of you are watching this
on odyssey maybe you are listening to it
on your favorite podcast distribution
app some of you may be watching it on
youtube you should be warned because
the sword of damocleth damn mccleese
continues to hangeth above the dark
horse
we will be terminating the stream on
youtube shortly after a brief
orientation to our censorship battle and
you will move over to odyssey you might
be more comfortable if you moved
now but if you're listening on a podcast
app or you're watching on aussie then
just sit back relax and
have a listen so the censorship battle
continues those of you who have not
read matt taibi's recent piece as of
yesterday on the current state of the
censorship battle
should do so i believe it is behind a
paywall
but i would say as a longtime subscriber
of mats
i believe his content is absolutely
worth
paying for and i would recommend signing
up for it maybe that piece will emerge
from behind the paywall at some point
but in any case it is excellent one of
the things that matt has found out
did we want to put that up yes could you
put up a it's here
image of that zach or yes there you go
here we can see
um matt's excellent piece one of the
things that he found out in talking to
youtube and apparently
youtube talking to anybody about who
they censor is pretty unusual
but one of the things that he found out
is that they apparently are in
consultation with governmental
authorities and
formulating their censorship policy
which obviously raises first amendment
questions um so
have a look at the article now as to
what we are doing
those of you who have been following us
closely know that youtube
demonetized both of our channels and
that it has effectively drawn a line in
the sand
it has invited us to reapply if we would
like but obviously
the quid pro quo would be one of our
self-censorship in order to rejoin
youtube's monetization program uh this
is this is inside baseball
and i know that if it that i wish i
didn't have to care about this
but demonetization and what was
happening to us before with the strikes
is actually somewhat different although
i went back and found some screenshots
of we've been
soft demonetized before which is where
we get
less ad revenue for the ads they're
they're rolling and in fact the first
time that they soft demonetized us
which is to say we're making less per
view than we were was after our very
first two live streams back in march of
2020.
now what were we talking about in those
first two live streams we were
disagreeing for instance with the us
surgeon general and the who at the time
uh having for having recently been
arguing that masks are useless and you
were basically laughable if you were
interested in wearing them
to protect yourself against coronavirus
that is the sort of uh
advice that we were giving back in march
2020 which seems to have prompted a soft
monotone by
demonetization by youtube then we have
in the last
uh boy what is it month to two months uh
had several videos taken down and had
and somehow each of which resulted um
the collective of which resulted in only
a single strike on each channel
which caused us to not be able to post
on either of those channels for a week
after that first strike
three strikes and you're out meaning
three strikes actually within a 90-day
period and you lose the channel
permanently
but this demonetization thing is sort of
outside of their strike system so they
seem to be making up the rules as they
go along
which um you know part of what we are
seeing and what we are pointing out
is this is exactly their this is what
they see as their right um you know
their platform
their rules and not only don't we get to
make them or question them we don't get
to know what they are at any given point
in time
so the demonetization means they're
going to keep running ads and they're
just going to take all the revenue from
those ads and we don't get any of it
effectively making our content
theirs yes um so we have been
removed from the monetization program
uh and that obviously as we have
mentioned
online uh removes more than half of our
family income
um that we are not going to be cowed by
this obviously we are talking about the
issues that we are discussing because
they are vitally important and we will
get uh to some of that importance later
on
in the live stream but uh
recognize that this leaves us in a
position where we
have to scramble and we have to find
sources of revenue to make up for that
and so
one of the things that we are doing is
we are releasing a
new pair of shirts that you could
purchase
to help us fight censorship and i think
you're really going to like this and
while i hesitate to call it a fact
the um the strong possibility that
everybody on your block is going to be
wearing one soon and you should be
first is uh something you should be
aware may be coming down the pipeline
well that's rather remarkable
yes i don't know why i said that but
anyway uh so let us
show some images of these shirts so this
is our new shirt and you can see for
those of you who are listening
and not watching it is a
beautiful t-shirt that has the
the word goliath spelled out in a way
that is perhaps reminiscent
of the uh type of presentation that is
sometimes deployed by our enemies here
and then let's show the back
of the shirt the back of the shirt says
don't be evil we've got that covered
all right so anyway these goliath shirts
are
uh i think going to be quite excellent
they are locally made
somewhere i have no doubt about that
certainly within the solar system they
are made of
humanely harvested cotton you don't know
so there was no suffering to the cotton
plants
whatsoever and they were kosher for
passover so
um i mean i wouldn't eat them but uh
actually you know there's a section of
catch-22 in which
milo minder binder attempts to do away
with a bunch of cotton that he's gotten
stuck with by
feeding it to people he does doesn't he
yes um yeah so
all right that is lurking so where can
they find these shirts where can they
find these shirts they can find these
shirts
at t spring slash i think
there's some words podcast
store.darkhorsepodcast.org and there is
a coupon code
for 10 off and the coupon code this
weekend i believe through this weekend
is divide by
and then the number zero so the word
divide by all
caps and the number zero which is our
invitation
to google that they should at their
earliest convenience
divide by zero and thereby solve the
censorship problem
all right um so i think we have arrived
at the point where we are going to end
the youtube stream
and hopefully everyone has comfortably
moved over to odyssey if you have not
the link is in the description and you
should do so now
and we will now start the official